ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد دعا نائب وزير
الخارجيه الروسيه جميع الاطراف الى
الاجتماع لمواجهه خطر الاسلحه البيولوجيه
مشيرا الى ان الخبراء الروس اكدوا بوجود
انشطه ومختبرات بيولوجيه في اوكرانيا نائب
وزير الخارجيه الروسيه تهمه في الوقت ذاته
واشنطن بتمويلي هذه المختبرات البيولوجيه
مؤكدا ان بلاده تمتلك ادله على تجارب
بيولوجيه اجرتها اوكرانيا قرب الحدود مع
روسيا من جهتها نشرت مجله بوليتكو نقلا عن
مسؤولين امريكا
للسلاح الكيماوي في اوكرانيا وذكرت المجله
وفق مسؤولين في اداره الرئيس الامريكي
وبعدين انا روسيا ستلجا الى استخدام تلك
الاسلحه قبل اي مواجهه النوويه مع حلفنيته
اذا ما استمرت القوات الروسيه بالتراجع
كما نقلت
المجلهائها لتصنيع ان كشف الاسلحه
الكيماويه وبالرغم من انه لا معلومات
استخباراتيه تؤكد نيه استخدامها الا ان
الولايات المتحده على درايه بقدره روسيا
الكيماويه ومخزونها
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من
موسكوتايمور دوار الخبير في قطع الاعمال
والعلاقات الدوليه اهلا بك ومنك فولو
ديمير شوماكو فادي بروماسيو السابق اهلا
بكم ضيوف الكرام الى هذه النشره واسمحوا
لي ان ابدا معك استاذ رضا همم هل نحن امام
اطار جديد من الصراع اسلحه بيولوجيه امام
اسلحه كيماويه هل يمكن ان ينفلت الموضوع
وتندلع الحرب في جزء جديد منها بهذه
العناوين تعتقد
ممكن نضيف ايضا الى هنا الاسلحه التيماويه
لان في الجيوش عاده هناك يوجد سلاح اه
الكيميائي او السلاح الكيميائي سلاح كقطعه
من عسكريه يعني في الجيش وهذه تستخدم في
المعركه الحاليه
لكن اسلحه كيماويه لا تستخدم
لان هناك اتفاقيه
بعدم انتشار الاسلحه البيولوجيه والحد
منها ومنها البيولوجيه والسامه
والمؤتمر انت ذكرتي جزء منها سوف يبدا في
جنيف يوم 28
اهم الاسئله التي العالم اذا سال عنها همم
ماذا تقوم به للولايات المتحده من تمويل
المعامل البيولوجيه في اوكرانيا في جورجيا
الحدود الروسيه وفي مناطق اخرى من العالم
الغرض من الثالث صح عن ذلك لان
الاتفاقيه للاسف الشديد لا تضم همم
الافصاح او امكانيه الافصاح او الاستفسار
حتى ثم الافصاح عن هذه الاسئله ومن سنه
2001 الولايات المتحده كما تعلمون ترفض
التعديل الاتفاقيه والنقاش فيها
همم همم
المشكله الكبرى الان قصف همم
الاوكرانيين بقياده همم غرفه العمليات
بقياده الامريكان
لمحطه زباله نوويه
يعني عدم المسؤوليه لدى الغرب او واشنطن
بالتحديد سبايدر كارتيه من صحيفه بوليتيكو
لان يعني
رائحه تاتي من هناك همم
عليهم همم ان ياخذوا في الاعتبار الامن
همم عليهم عدم استهداف همم محطه زبرجيا
على الاقل انما الاسلحه الكيميائيه نحن
تحدثنا معك من قبل عن منظومات توست همم
وغيرها مجرد داخل
همم
نسيت او همم الكتائب الخاصه بالعمليات ال-
همم الحرب الكيميائيه فقط لكن لا يوجد
في المقابل كان هناك حديث سيد همم
على همم ان اوكرانيا والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه على فكره هذا الموضوع لم يطرح
او لم يطرحه فقط نائب وزير الخارجيه روسي
سرغراف حتى من قبل لو تتذكر في شهر مارس
كانت هناك جلسه طارئه ادعت اليها روسيا
ممثل روسيا وقتها تحدث عن ادله تمتلكها
موسكو وهذه الادله همم تتمثل في
تفعيل او انتاج اوكرانيا لاسلحه بيولوجيه
بدعم امريكيه
فهذه المره لما يعيدها من جديد ويعيد طرحه
نائب وزير الخارجيه روس ويقول بان لدينا
ادله وسنقدمها الى اي مدى كل هذا دقيق
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
يعني ذهب الى الاعتقاد بانه في اوله هو
نوع من الاسلحه التي كانت موجوده في
المختبرات كانت هناك تساؤلات كل الاجهزه
الرسميه ولكن همم الاسلحه البيولوجيه تضرب
الاطراف فتتعلم سيد امير
انا اقول انا الاول الاس الحاكم ويا حول
كمان استخدام الجنود رؤوس واين موجودين
السكان اوكران في هذه المناطق مثلا في
جنوب اوكراني او في منطقه هذا من المستحيل
اوكرانيا
اين موجود
يعني في حاله تسريب الاشاعه سوف تكون
المصممه
اوكراني هو خاصه
نحن بصراحه نعرف ما هذا ولذلك كي معطات
انا اعتقد بانه هذا استفزازات روسيه روسيا
طفاشل الوهاب حاربوا عندي شواخ الجلديه
بانروسه من الممكن سوف
[موسيقى]
تستخدمته من مصطلحات لضيفي الاستاذ تيمور
استاذ تيمور هل هي دعايه هي استفزازات
روسيه ضيف يقول بانه هذا الترويش هو
بروباندا روسيه لخدمه همم اسلحه ستستخدمها
موسكو فعليه بمعنى انه ما اسكت ابحث عن
تعلم الكيماوي فتتحدث عن تحضير واشنطن
وهوكرانيا لاسلحه بيولوجيه حتى تكون لها
بعض ال- ال- او تعلم هذا شماعات حتى على
اثرها تستخدم اسلحه كيماويه هل يمكن ان
يكون هذا الكلام دقيق تعتقد
ربما لو كنا جالسين على مقهى عربي
ونتحدث ليس على شاشه قناه مرموقه اه ولا
نناقش موضوع يخص الامن العالمي عندما
نتحدث عن ال- همم
ما يخص السلاح البيولوجي ومسببات الامراض
ليس روسيا فقط هناك دول العده من بريكس
والصين اه يعني دول كثيره تتسائل لي
الولايات المتحده ماذا تفعلون
بتلك همم
المعامل واين تلك مسببات الامراض هل نقلت
الى الولايات المتحده يعني هناك عندنا
تساؤلات ماذا فعلتم واين نتائج الابحاث لن
نتحدث عن ما يتحدث السيد المحترم من
اوكرانيا يعني هو يتحدث عن اشياء تخص ربما
المقهى نحن لان نتحدث عن ان عالمي
الحرف فهي ستستخدم سلاح قادر ان يقويها في
المستقبل
هذه منصه لحريه الراي ونشكركم عليها ممكن
يقول ايضا ان الجنود الروس
النساء الاوكرانيات ايضا بيولوجيا او
العكس صحيح فا- همم كله يعني هي منصه انا
اتحدث عن شيء مهم انا يعني لدي
سمعه وخبره فيما نحن بنتبحت في امور كبيره
لا نتعب احد في اشياء خاصه
بقزقزت اللب وهمم
يقول بان هذا الموضوع لا يستحق حتى النقاش
نحن في اطار تطورات عميقه يعيشها العالم
والترويج لمثل هكذا افكار سيزر حتى ظل
علاقات واكثر سيضر حتى بتطورات هذه الازمه
والله ممكن ننتظر كل شيء من روسيا
عليها ارهابيه عروسه
لماذا نسمع كلامه ولا نرى ادله لما يتحدث
الاوكرانيون عن ان موسكو تتحضر لاستخدام
اسلحه كيماويه وليست هناك لا معلومات
استخباراتيه ولا تصريحات اا تضعنا في
تفاصيل همم هذه المعلومات فكيف نصدق
ما صرخه روسيه فتفاضل ممكن هي سوف تقدم
ولكن عموما مصاعب روسيه هي هي فارغه
بالمناسبه حتى كلمه عروسه
همم
هذه مسرحيه روسيه بصراحه
هل نحن في اطار الحديث عن اتهامات
واتهامات مقابله همم للضغط على مفاوضات
كما يقول سيف الوترمير او ان الموضوع اخطر
من سالك او ان الموضوع قادر ان يحملنا الى
زله قد تستعمل على اثرها هذه النوعيه من
الاسلحه الخطيره
اوكرانيا مجرد حدث عابر في هذا الموضوع
لان اول اكتشاف لهذا المعامل حدث في
جورجيا واعتقد كان هناك اثار في
اوزباكستان ودول اخرى خارج نطاق النفوذ
الروسي او الاتحاد السوفيتي السابق
فالموضوع كبير للغايه وهو موضوع عالمي
ودولي انما ان رجعنا لما قاله اا
سيد المحترم من كيف او من اوكرانيا انا
اتفهمه تماما من حيث التحسر على ما الوضع
همم الموجود من حيث المبدا
والموجود ميدانيا ايضا لان هذه ارض واحده
همم ناس واحده
مثل بمثابه حرب اهليه نشاهدها ولا يوجد
همم وكل الاساليب في القتال مباحه بما
فيها همم الامنيات والتصريحات
وانا اتفهم اتفهمه وهو شخصيا واتفهم من
معه في ذلك لكن هناك يجب ان يكون
ااا واي سياسي همم اولا ااا نحن فعلا شعب
واحد ولا ندري تاريخيا من من هو الذي
سيحكم في المستقبل ان كان اوكراني روسي
كذاخي
ممثل مثلا من اصول عربيه الله اعلم همم
البلد الموحده التي سوف نتوصل اليها
مستقبلا ربما انا قربما في نطاق هذه
المناوشات التي اشهدها بعد تفكر الاتحاد
السوفيتي لكن
اه الموضوع
خراب بيوت الناس تموت الناس تحتضر ربما
الان من
من نعم نتيجه القصف نتيجه للمعارك
الابرياء يعني يعني الموضوع
ذلك لكن
لماذا اه وصل الموضوع الى هذه الدرج يعني
انا وايضا
متاثر بما يحدث لانه يجب عليه يعني فرض
قانون بعدم التعامل مع بوتر اوكي لا تريد
التعامل مع بروتين خليه وزير الدفاع
الالكتروني يتعامل مع وزير الدفاع الروسي
او القياده
بطريقه
صحيحه
ولكن لاني بقتلي بعض لحظات ساختمها معك
السيد
في 30 ثانيه
التعامل من وجهه نظري شاب اوكراني بنسبه
يتعامل مع عبود
الان بعض التراجع روس من مدينه خيرسون
خلال هذه ايام روسيا تساقط ستقاس بشكل
[موسيقى]
روسي
والموضوع سيبقى دائما للمتابعه من
كيفولتيميرش
قطع الاعمال والعلاقات الدوليه شكرا لكم
الى فاصل ومن بعده
تقرير الامم يكشف عن قتل خمس نساء كل ساعه
على ايدي اقاربهن فكيف فكيف نحن النساء
وهل القانون كاف ام لا بد من تغير ثقافه
النظره الى المراه